NARRATOR: The 1941 bombing of
Pearl Harbor by the Japanese
was one of the most devastating
attacks on American soil.
But just a few decades earlier,
Japan and the United States
were allies in World
War I. So how did
things get so bad between them?
It all comes down to oil.
To explain, we need
to go all the way
back to the 19th century.
Once an isolated nation, Japan
underwent a makeover of sorts
to compete with the West.
Known as the Meiji Restoration,
it embraced industrialization,
built up its military, and
restored Japan's emperor
as the powerful head of state.
Aided by two successful,
wars Japan aggressively
expanded its empire.
The Japanese were becoming
an imperial superpower
until the Great Depression hit.
You see, Japan is
an island nation
with few natural resources.
So it depends on
international trade
to keep its economy afloat.
The economic crisis
put a stop to all that.
Japan was in a bind.
So its military leaders, who
called the shots at this point,
decided the best defense
against financial ruin
would be a good offense.
They would invade nearby
China, particularly Manchuria,
for its plentiful resources like
iron, soybeans, and land, lots
and lots of unsettled land.
So what does this all have
to do with the United States?
Well, the US was a
longstanding Chinese ally.
And it watched uneasily
from the sidelines
as the two nations
clashed in the 1930s.
But America wanted nothing
to do with another war,
so it just denounced
Japan's aggression.
Tensions rose in 1937,
when Japan invaded
the Chinese city of Nanjing.
In doing so, they attacked
an American gunboat, killing
three and wounding dozens.
Disturbing images coming
out of war-torn China
further swayed American
opinion against Japan.
In response, America
attacked Japan's resources.
They imposed economic
sanctions of aircraft,
scrap metal, and other items
crucial to Japan's military.
The US hoped the sanctions
would stop Japanese expansion.
But Japan doubled down, invading
French Indochina in 1940,
and then teaming up
with Germany and Italy.
Why those two countries?
Because like Japan,
they were controlled
by militaristic governments
obsessed with conquest
and driven by a deep
sense of nationalism.
The final straw
came in July of 1941
when President Franklin
D. Roosevelt announced
a trade embargo on oil.
An oil shortage was
an absolute disaster
for Japan, who relied on
imports for 90% of its supply.
Not only would this destroy
the Japanese economy,
but it would put its military
at a literal standstill,
which meant no more expansion.
Japan resented the
US for meddling
in its quest to dominate Asia.
The only solution left for
the Japanese was total war--
crush the US fleet
in the Pacific
and then occupy Southeast
Asia and claim its resources.
And so on December 7, 1941,
Japan launched its surprise
attack at Pearl Harbor.
[sirens]
At first, it seemed like
a win for the Japanese,
destroying or damaging 21
US ships and more than 300
aircraft, and killing
around 2,400 soldiers,
sailors, airmen, and civilians.
But the success was short-lived.
The United States declared war
on Japan on December 8, 1941.
Not long after, the Japanese
would realize the mistake
it made at Pearl Harbor.
Their bombers had failed
to deliver a mortal blow
to the Pacific
fleet, missing oil
tanks, ammunition sites,
repair facilities,
and aircraft carriers.
Just six months later,
remnants of the US fleet
would score a key
victory against Japan
at the Battle of
Midway, turning the tide
of the war against the
once mighty Japanese.
[music playing]